the latest of Donald Trump's picks for
his cabinet have raised concerns among
environmental groups and policy makers X
Texas Governor Rick Perry has been
chosen as the energy secretary a man he
wanted to dismantle the very Department
he'll set to be in charge of and earlier
this week mr. chomp picked ExxonMobil
see Oh Rex Tillerson Secretary of State
an oil executive whom many insist will
undermine global action to address
climate change well earlier I spoke to
Professor of a political science Peter
Mathews the author of the book dollar
democracy he's got three people there an
oilman in the sector of state and he's
got Rick Perry the circuit of the Energy
Department and he would be Texas all
supporter of oil and also and they got
Scott Pruett who's the appointee for the
EPA Environmental Protection Agency
that's a three-pronged attack on clean
energy and conservation and a fight
against global warming it's actually
saying that Donald Trump believes what
he said earlier that global warming is a
hoax that's what he said if I call it a
Chinese a Chinese government plot to
derail the US economy so even though
he's backtracked a little bit on that it
looks like his appointments and his
actions are speaking louder than words
it's kind of a shame in a way because we
have I mean China is very concerned the
u.s. may withdraw from the Paris accords
which is so important which all the
countries in the world of sign basically
into the United States if we withdraw
it'll be a big blow to climate
distribute stop climate disruption let's
talk about the reasons behind Donald
Trump's choice here first of all with
Rick Perry he's put him and nominating
to head out the energy department which
he wanted to actually dismantle why do
you think Donald Trump would choose him
for this over there a reason I believe
because this is an intent an attempt to
deregulate the economy meaning these
very cabinet departments are established
by in the government you know at the
beginning the country's history we're
there in order to write the rules that
would implement legislation in those
given areas so in the energy area that
the Congress passes laws about energy
and the energy department writes the
rules and then implements the rules so
if you put someone in charge of
implementing the rules and then slowed
them that make him slow the rules down
and not or dismantle the rules you're
deregulating the energy industry and
you're actually creating a lot of
problems for four
regulation and that's I think what
Donald Trump wants he's argued that
there's too much regulation now we can
deregulate the economy more in so many
areas that business can make more money
and it will trickle down it'll go
everyone will prosper that they'll be
hiring more people investing more it's
an old theory of Ronald Reagan's
innocence it's kind of a three a
trickle-down economics theory and more
concern concerning about that is the
fact that climate were beyond the pale
we're getting very close to that in
climate change two degrees centigrade
above rising temperatures is chaotic and
we're at 1.7 right now so it's very
important single extreme weather
conditions going on and most of the
countries of the world actually agree on
this and even the largest economy
besides our is China second largest I
has agreed to do that to sign this and
the United States withdrawing would be a
horrible horrible setback there were
reasons the founders set up a cabinet to
carry out the laws they were there
written and to have some regulation in
place well let's take a look at why
Donald Trump claims that he's put em
Rick Perry as head of the Energy
Department he says he's a man who's come
from a business climate that's produced
millions of new jobs and lowered energy
prices and he's really again sticking to
that promise that he wants to put people
we've got a good business background a
good successful background in place in
his administration surely that's a good
thing it would be if you don't go to the
extreme and do so much be regulation
that you actually hurt the very people
you're supposed to be helping if we have
climate disruption continue it's going
to cost cost us so much in terms of the
coastal lines and the insurance costs
going up with this to severe storms and
that will defeat any purpose of making
the economy grow for the working people
or for middle-class people anyone even
though LT will suffer with this so he
has to be very careful about this and
not roll back so many of the importantly
game legislation and regulations that
are based on real science i mean the
IPCC the international panel of climate
change has come out most all of the
scientists of the world about
ninety-five percent or more have said
that climate change is caused by human
activity because the temperatures when I
rising skyrocketing in the last hundred
years since industrialization began
hundred fifty years so this is based on
science and Donald Trump needs to go
with the science I understand the need
to allow business to have you know
entrepreneurs ship and beer
for it and not over regulated but there
really has to be a balance I think that
Donald Trump needs to make sure he
doesn't overstep the balance most people
are very concerned about this including
some Republicans who are very sensible
about the need for sensible regulations
in all areas of the economy